all right
everybody the debate is ending right now
i missed the last two minutes because i
had to
get in here and put in my earpiece and
put on my microphone and get smacked
with powder so i don't look shiny for
you good people
well i think that was sort of just
kind of what i predicted this morning
not to say i told you so but
i told you so before we get into any of
the specifics though and i want to find
out
uh what you guys were eating and
drinking during this event i
was drinking tequila we got a nice
sipping tequila here friends the other
night brought us this great
fancy bottle i don't even know what this
is but i was told it's a very fancy
bottle of tequila
and we were sipping it the other night
and it was a long night
and that's what i'm going to be drinking
with you people and i got one of my
fancy ice cubes i know
last time i had a fancy ice cube i had a
stormtrooper
helmet ice cube i believe this is the
death star
you know we spare no expense in terms of
ice around here and i'm gonna be doing a
little tequila with you guys
and talking about politics
here we go um all right first off what i
predicted this morning
and what i said online for the last
couple days basically was that trump
needed to do
one thing tonight and that was be
presidential
that was it that really was it and if
you hate trump
if you like trump whatever it is i'm
pretty sure
you can acknowledge that he was
presidential tonight he didn't attack he
didn't speak over anybody he was
respectful of the moderator he was
actually pretty respectful
of biden and i think this was
for the group of people who i still
think haven't decided what i think those
mostly are
are lifelong or long-term democrats
who are finally going i've had enough of
the democratic party i don't believe in
this thing anymore and i don't like
this crazy left thing coming behind
biden
but i'm still a little nervous about
trump i understand
what that is and that was me for a long
long time and i suppose one of the
reasons
that you guys watch this show and and
listen to some of the things that i talk
about
is that i've been open about my own
political evolution
and i'm not sitting here as someone
that's got a laminated uh
you know republican card like i don't
and i would
and i don't really consider myself part
of any party at this point although if i
was to look at the two parties
which which of the two parties is more
in line with the things that i now
believe
about getting the government out of my
life well that's definitely the
republican party they aren't that good
at it either
but it but it's certainly better than
the democratic party but i understand
the feelings of those people who have
sort of had it with the democrats it's
why the walk away movement has become so
powerful
it's why the black voices for trump and
brexit movements have become so powerful
and many other movements like that it's
it's why
there was a poll out from a week ago
uh with more than 1200 respondents which
is pretty solid for one of these polls
often they'll show you an mbc poll and
it's got like 600 people and they'll
tell you that that's somehow
an indicator of something much wider but
there was a poll out last week that
something like 45
of gay men are gonna vote for donald
trump so the
the traditional groups that vote
democratic
either are not going to vote democratic
or are really struggling with it and i
think all trump really had to do tonight
10
10 or so days before the election was be
presidential because he was not
presidential in the first one there's
there's no doubt about it right
and there's reasons for it i think you
can make actually pretty solid reasons
for it because he was debating chris
wallace as much as he was
debating joe biden and we can get into
all of that stuff but that's already
behind us at this point
i think he had to show people that he's
competent
that he cares that he knows what he's
doing and the rest of it and i think he
basically did do that tonight now before
i get to by
let me just say a little more on that
which is that part of the problem
and i've been telling you guys this for
quite some time now
is that we are in a reality war that is
what this is people think we're in a
political war or a cultural war but what
i really think
is that we're in a reality war and that
reality work contains
battles like the political battle which
we're seeing that's what tonight's all
about
and the cultural battle which is about
our institutions and colleges and what
hollywood puts out and everything else
but but the reality war is the thing up
here and then the
the battles the political battles
cultural battles are beneath it and by
reality war i mean that
in effect if you if you were watching
that debate tonight and depending on
what you're watching right now if you
i'm assuming you're watching this a lot
of you guys obviously watch these on
mobile devices but
it's late night now in most places so
you're probably watching at a computer
maybe you're watching this on apple tv
or something but you also might have a
tv in the room
and the things that i'm going to say
here directly to you which just
come out of my brain con tequila
are going to be very different it's a
very different type of conversation that
i'm having with you and i believe it to
be a conversation
than than what you're going to see on
msnbc on fox news on cnn or abc or
or elsewhere we watched the abc coverage
for a few minutes before the debate
and george stephanopoulos this is the
head anchor the head news guy at abc
news and he was
bill clinton's communications director
okay
he was a bill clinton staffer do you
think he's a democrat or a republican i
mean every
person that they had on there except for
the exception of this one woman
was clearly a democrat term turn on any
of the network news and it's all
democrats and they're obviously
democrats
so they they don't want to give you
something fair so i'm trying my best
truly to give you something fair while
at the same time telling you that
i'm obviously voting for trump and i
think that the left has gone completely
bananas and i think
that trump is is basically the last
chance we have
to stand up against big tech to stand up
against the radical leftism that's
rampaging through the institutions
and i don't think biden can do it now
now biden
did have an interesting moment tonight
where he said i beat those guys the
implication
like i don't believe in any of that
crazy leftist stuff either even though
at the same time
all of his positions are suddenly
becoming bernie's positions and if you
look at biden's twitter
it's clearly been taken over by a bernie
type person because it's just
meaningless bernie slogan after
meaningless bernie slogan
but but what's interesting here and why
this is a tough move for biden is if
he's
saying well i'm not those guys i'm the
moderate well then the bass hates you
man
and actually i think in a weird way he'd
like it if the bass hates him because
that would at least be passionate
there's no passion
behind behind biden and passion whether
hate or love
are usually good in politics one way or
another it keeps it keeps the machine
going right
the indifference to biden i think is the
bigger problem
so so just to clean up on the trump part
so trump i thought
effectively composed himself
was presidential you either you either
agree with what he said or don't
the reality war part of this is when
he's saying things about hunter biden
and the laptop when he's saying things
about the economy when he's saying
things about all-time low black
unemployment and hispanic unemployment
and the rest of it well
i know that most of those things are
true right and as
as scott adams says trump is
directionally true meaning sometimes he
exaggerates things we all know that
right the biggest the best
but he's directionally true that the
basic thing that what he's saying is
usually true and then he
he uh you know he paints around the
edges let's say
um now you're going to believe that if
you listen to a certain type of news but
if you listen to mainstream news you're
going to hear
all of that filtered through people that
are going to tell you that everything he
said there was lies
the best example i can give you of this
right this very moment
like 20 minutes before the debate
tonight there's a woman by the name of
simone sanders she was bernie sanders
campaign manager i actually met her at a
at a 2016 um debate when i was trying to
get bernie on the show
and i was in the like the they called
the spin room because that's where they
feed you nonsense basically um i was in
the spin room and she was there and i
said hi to her and i was trying to get
bernie on the show we exchanged
a bunch of emails and then it just
didn't go anywhere and by the way i was
a i was a lefty at the time
but she was on msnbc about 20 minutes
before uh
the debate and she said that if
if trump talks about hunter biden and
the laptop et cetera et cetera
that he's going to be giving russian
disinformation now the head
of the national intelligence the
director of the national intelligence
ratcliffe
he has said and it's even on
cnnfreaking.com
that there is no reason to believe that
this laptop story
is russian misinformation so this is why
i talk about a reality war that that is
bigger than the
cultural war or the political war
because depending on what
news you watch and and who's what
sources you get things from and whether
twitter will allow tweets to be up
to say some things but not others the
war is about reality it's
just not about politics so for example
the new york post story i know most of
you guys know this but this new york
post story about hunter and the
and the laptop and everything that
happened with ukraine i don't need to
even get into all the nitty gritty
details right now
new york post has been locked out of
twitter for six days
well congratulations twitter you have
amplified
the story you've shown that big tech
sensors and you've shown the light on
the fact
that everyone else is allowed to lie
about everything right
and and we're allowed to expose things
all the time without proper sources
trump's taxes for example
like we're always allowed to do it
except not this time so that's why the
reality war is here and
and i what i fear more than anything
else truly what i fear more than
anything else
is that if trump loses that's it that's
it they'll never
trump has mapped out for people on the
right conservatives libertarians
whatever he has mapped out how you fight
the monster and he mapped it out either
fully by design or by accident or it
feels like some crazy science fiction
story but he became president
this orange hair plug the guy he mapped
it out he became president he fought
back
and now the system is reconfiguring
itself through big
tech and censorship and through
mainstream media
and the democratic establishment those
are the big three things and they're all
fighting against it and we have an
election in 10 days to decide
do you want to be censored forever i
mean even so let's move to biden for a
second so biden
you know for the first 20 minutes they
talked about coronavirus which by the
way
i i vaguely remember i think someone
told me this fauci said if you
sip tequila that's the number one cure
of uh of corona buyers so
yeah yeah i can feel it going away um
they were talking about coronavirus at
the beginning and
biden repeatedly said what he has said
consistently throughout
which is something to the effect of
we'll continue the lockdowns we'll be in
i would have done a nationwide lockdown
these are not good things these are not
good things do you want to leave your
house again
like biden's campaign slogan basically
should be joe biden live in your
basement
i do like what what is he saying nobody
what are you more affected by i mean
really think about this this is what
trump should have said
trump should have turned to him when he
said that and said or he should have
said it to the camera because biden's
very good at that direct to the camera
thing you know
either the american people or they're at
the kitchen table and they don't have
tires or
i mean scranton or whatever he always
says but what trump's response to him
needed to be to the average person he
needed to say hey listen
we understand that that coronavirus
happened that it's happening we're not
done with it
but we can't fully end our lives which
is partly what he said but then he
needed to say
which has hurt you more think about the
difference
in your minute to minute life which is
affecting you more
the fact that there's a virus out there
that 99.9 of people recover from and
usually only kills old people and that's
not to diminish
anyone that has died from it or been
sick by it and i know people that have
been sick by it i know several people
around my age who got it
and then recovered i do i know one
person
who is about 85 who did get it and and
died from it
so it's not to diminish any of that but
think about what has happened to our
lives the restaurants that are closing
the sneaker stores that are closing the
malls that are closed
bowling alleys movie theaters we have
fundamentally
changed this entire country destroyed
lives we know that alcoholism is up we
know that suicide rates are up all of
these things these are all true
things and those are results of our
actions
dealing with coronavirus okay we can fix
this thing meaning we have to go out
there and in life
there is some risk ben shapiro was on my
show
probably back in may or so and he said
something that was very obvious and very
true and it was the number one trend on
twitter
because the losers at media matters made
it sound like it was something it wasn't
in effect he said there's going to be
some risk to reopen we can never get it
to a place where we have an
absolute cure or zero people are gonna
die or nobody's gonna get sick
that is just a fact life is about risk
and you're not gonna believe this and
this is
in effect what ben said there are people
called actuaries and do you know what
they do it's a very very boring job my
friend brian's an actuary he's the most
boring guy i know
and he all day long looks at equations
to figure out the person's age the
person's height the person's weight the
person's habits do they smoke do they do
drugs family history
how much can we insure them for what is
what is house insurance about
do you know if what if you have a big
house that's in
on a top of a hill and the foundation
ain't great well you're gonna probably
have to pay a lot in insurance
well there's risk there's risk in life
that's what it is
and we are going to have to open up
again or we can just live
underground forever which it sort of
sounds like what biden's saying because
we have to open up again so this idea
that
i'm not only am i going to fix it but
it's going to be a national fix when we
know that obviously what's going on in
new york
is way different than what's going on in
omaha
it's it's such a crazy proposition think
about it you
person watching this on youtube right
now which has affected you more the
virus
or our response to the virus we have to
open up the country again we need
to let people live again lines to get
into stores even now
just going i i had a dentist appointment
today okay i had my teeth
cleaned today i had to wear a mask while
sitting in the chair
before the cleaning now i did most of
the cleaning with my mouth open right
okay and they're sticking things in your
mouth there's two women in there some
other guy walked in
but i had to sit with a mask in the
chair before they got in there
none of this makes any sense they took
my temperature when i got in they asked
me some questions i wasn't sick
why are we why are we shutting down
everything and changing our way of life
so if you want to live this way
potentially forever
because that's they seem to want to
eliminate risk altogether then i suppose
you should
vote for joe biden uh i think trump
could have hit that a little bit harder
he hit it a bit
this idea that we have to open up again
but i think he could uh he could have
really made the point
but i think but this is sort of
nitpicking a little bit um so
let's let's throw to some clips though
because there was a lot happening there
and i don't want to just pontificate
on my feelings about the whole thing i
want to show you clips and analyze clips
uh so the first this was this was around
the corona stuff at that beginning
portion
uh this was a little trump zinger he
didn't have too many zingers tonight
there weren't there weren't a lot of
zingers it wasn't a knight of zingers
although biden had the line what was it
about the
the dog whistle the size of a fog horn
yeah obviously the quartermaster is his
comedy writer i mean it's like where are
you getting these references and biden's
thing about
you're sitting at the kitchen table and
you can't find your toaster and your
clock is missing and your sister's
wheels aren't on her car like none of
that stuff works anymore man it just
feels
man you know he goes man at the end come
on man
it's like you're trying to be human
biden but 47 years in
it doesn't really work anymore anyway
let's throw to a rare moment of a zinger
by the president reaction over soon i
say we're learning to live with it we
have no choice we can't lock ourselves
up in a basement like
joe does he has the he has the ability
to lock himself up i don't know he's
obviously made a lot of money someplace
but he has this thing about living in a
basement people can't do that
by the way i as the president couldn't
do that i'd love to put myself in the
basement or in a beautiful room in the
white house
and go away for a year and a half until
it disappears i can't do that
there's your basement line for you i
mean it was it was a pretty solid line
and and trump had it pre-packaged and
and ready to go um but i thought it was
it was
emblematic of sort of what i'm laying
out there like do you want to live in
your basement forever pretty much like
putting aside like them hiding
biden for the last couple days and they
obviously hide him to rest him up
and it's like i don't know how what
they're drugging him with or how they're
keeping him focused or is he snorting
adderall right before he goes on or
like i don't know what they're doing but
like he he didn't lose his train of
thought too much he had one or two
moments where it seemed like it could
just spin out of control you know he has
those senior moments where he's talking
and he's stumbling and stumbling and you
can sort of feel like it's gonna just
like cascade completely disastrously but
but it never did
it it never did and i think that as i
said this morning
i think that this format was was
although i think they did it
intentionally to hurt trump so that he
couldn't
you know sort of be on the attack as
much i thought that there was a chance
that it would hurt biden more because
biden would have to do
you know these two three-minute speeches
where
that's where he tends to lose his words
and everything he didn't
really do it there were some moments
where it was a little dicey but he
didn't really do it
uh but let's jump back to the to the
lockdowns this is trump this is clip two
uh trump talking about why we can't
close up the nation
kirsten every every meeting i had every
meeting i had and i'd meet a lot of
families including gold star families
and military families
every meeting i had and i had to meet
them i had to it would be horrible to
have canceled everything
i said you know this is dangerous and
you catch it and you know i caught it i
learned a lot
i learned a lot great doctors great
hospitals
and now i recovered 99.9
of young people recover 99
of people recover we have to recover we
can't close up our nation we have to
open our school
and we can't close up our nation or
you're not going to have
you know on watching that clip again and
i've got the text of it right here i
actually want to slightly backtrack on
what i was saying a few minutes ago
because i was basically saying that
trump didn't hit hard back enough
on this idea that we have to open up but
the line we can't close up our nation or
we're not going to have a nation is
pretty good
i think i think there's still a way to
make it feel a little more personal not
doing the hokey kitchen table thing
but really kind of connecting it with
people about how their lives
have been affected and how their lives
have been in many cases destroyed i mean
i'm not making this thing up about the
rampant rates of alcoholism and suicide
and everything else i'm also noticing i
don't know if you guys are noticing this
i'm noticing a lot of people
who've gained a lot of weight in the
midst of this whole thing like you know
people are eating worse you're not
getting out as much all those things
you're not going to the gym
right like i i have a elliptical machine
here i try to get on there for an hour a
day
uh but you know it's like not everybody
has that luxury
so i'll slightly people don't do this on
on the youtube or on television but i'm
gonna slightly walk back what i said
earlier because i think maybe trump did
a slightly better job of it
than i thought um then they got into
the hunter biden stuff and and some of
joe's deals now
i don't want to get into the minutia of
this at some level because
in a certain way it's like we've all got
problems in life right now like we've
got the lockdown situation
we've got kovid we have we have racial
strife although i don't think it's real
racial strife i don't think we have real
racists running around i think we have
people who purport to be anti-racists
who are telling everyone they're racist
so we have sort of
a reverse racist uh
with a reverse racist lens that we're
looking
looking at the world through which is
which is pretty weird um
but they started getting so i'd rather
focus on on those things
in a certain way but trump was trying to
hit uh
biden on some of the stuff involving
hunter but also the fact that biden has
made a lot of money as president obvious
as vice president
as senator obviously um this is what
they do
right like they use their power for a
while and then they make all sorts of
money
i assure you that barack obama is making
a ton of money right now in books
and advances and his deal with netflix
and and all sorts of other things and
i'm not even saying that that's
so terrible it's like if you were the
president of the united states and you
make some money after
like okay so be it now i suppose at some
level if you're using all of your
connections to do those things
then it's problematic i don't really
like the word problematic i don't know
why i said it i think it was the tequila
um but you know it's like the media has
focused so hard on trump's kids right
trump he donald trump jr is on the
campaign trail for him and ivanka
does this thing in the white house and
jared kushner blah blah blah now jared
kushner did start doing the piece in the
middle east thing
and uh you know trump's children
actually are are huge defenders
of him but they also were private
citizens before all of this
it's very obvious like this is just the
truth
this is not left this is not right it is
very obvious
that hunter biden got a job
at charisma because of his dad's
connections
and then took a job that he was not
qualified for in any way for 50
000 a month at least some people say it
was more actually
and then leverage that leverage that
because of his dad's connections now
there's these emails on this computer
and
the fbi is saying there's no reason to
think it's russian misinformation so do
we believe the fbi or not do we believe
the acting intelligence director or not
well you can go on msnbc as i said
earlier and be
abide in spokeswoman and say that it's
russian misinformation and no one on
msc's nbc is going to correct you
again brings us back to that reality war
i was talking about
uh so let's talk let's throw to clip
number three and this is trump
uh talking about how biden owes an
explanation about about
all this stuff i sold while he was
selling pillows and sheets
i sold tank busters to ukraine there has
been nobody
tougher than on russia than donald trump
and i'll tell you they were so bad they
took over the
the submarine port you remember that
very well
during your term during you and barack
obama
they took over a big part of what should
have been ukraine you handed it to him
but you were getting a lot of money from
russia
they were paying you a lot of money and
they probably still are
but now with what came out today it's
even worse
all of the emails the emails the
horrible emails of the kind of money
that you were raking
in you and your family and joe you were
vice president when some of this was
happening
and it should have never happened and i
think you owe an explanation to the
american people
why is it somebody just had a news
conference a little while
ago who was essentially supposed to work
with you and your family
but what he said was damning and
regardless of me i think you have to
clean it up and talk to the american
people maybe you can do it
all right so again the question on a
clip like that is how much do people
actually care about this stuff do we
just expect our politicians to be
corrupt which most most of them are and
if so then do you actually care if biden
did all this stuff
and then beyond that do you even get the
information that any do you even buy
into the fact that any of that could
possibly be true
and that that is the question that
remains to be answered i i just don't
know where people fall on that i just
don't that's one of those ones where
it's really hard to bust out of your
echo chamber it's like it can
feel very big to some people right if
you're if you're on the right right now
you're right leaning this hunter thing
and the emails
and the money and all that it seems very
big and if you're on the left well you
probably just don't even hear about it
so how how do we have a national
conversation
about anything again that's that's the
biggest issue of the day
that is the reality war so we've got
we've got two more clips for you
uh that were two of my favorite moments
both of these were
were sort of spectacular uh let's go to
clip number four
this is joe biden and i have a feeling
he's not going to be invited
to uh thanksgiving dinner at the obamas
anytime soon because he
just threw barack under the bus here we
go
what i'm going to do is pass obamacare
with a public option
become biden care the public option is
an option that says that
if you in fact do not have the
wherewithal to be if you
qualify for medicaid and you do not have
the wherewithal
then your state to get medicaid you
automatically are enrolled
providing competition for insurance
companies that's what's gonna
ah that's the cult of personality of
this stuff for you
it's not obamacare anymore because
obamacare didn't really do it sure it
was the thing that we said was the best
thing ever and it was obama's trademark
signature moment of his entire
presidency and i was vice president for
it but yeah
that thing he did forget about a couple
things so we're gonna do
biden care uh
yeah i mean all right so we're gonna do
it or not but this is also where they
got into the thing about pre-existing
conditions and trump is saying that his
plan will have it bidens
biden is saying that no it's not gonna
happen and again it's like well who do
you trust who do you trust i don't i
actually don't know which one
to trust on this like it's like i need
to see the plans we need to actually
see what's going to happen but just
because they say things i mean and again
this gets to
why the biden thing is so sort of
ridiculous at so many levels
you got you had 47 years to do all of
this
why didn't you do any of it if you have
all the plans right
you got all the plans you got all the
paper i know how to do this i know how
to do this we can move this here carry
the one we're going to get this going
okay let's do that
well then why didn't you do any of it so
the biden campaign just doesn't make any
sense because he either didn't know how
to do any of it
or or is lying about knowing how to do
it or was just negligent
all of those years how do you get around
that as a biden supporter please
let me know i would love to know what
the thinking of is if you're if you're a
biden supporter if you think that this
77 year old man
is the guy that is supposed to get us
into the next
uh decade if you think this is the man
that's supposed to lead the country
then you got to explain well why didn't
he do any of these things why is he
running against his base at some level
right he's running against the bernie
base i suppose
and he's running against obama and and
it's like you know he does the thing
that all the democrats
do hillary did it and kamala does it all
the time which is every time someone
makes a good point
they just laugh it off they just smile
you know they just smile because it's
like they don't have to do anything
because
what he's smiling at he's basically
going ha ha you could say whatever you
want don then the media ain't going to
call me out on it right they're not
going to call me out of my
my twitter account isn't going to be
shadow band no bad story about me
is is going to get buried so it's like
god it's all gross okay we got four
minutes left and then i'm jumping over
to the blaze i'm going to be on with
glenn back in a few minutes i think it's
tequila time before we uh
throw to clip number five which was oh
this is a good one
this is a good one there was i told you
there were only a couple couple zingers
this was an accidental self zinger by
joe
man that is good that is uh gran
reserva a sombroso ultrafino
100 agave little vanilla in there i
think all right
uh so this is clip number five and yeah
we weren't gonna get through a debate
without mentioning hitler
so let's talk about hitler clip number
five
and that's okay you know what north
korea we're not in a war
we have a good relationship you know
people don't understand having a good
relationship with leaders of other
countries
we have a lot of questions to get to
know that's right man we had a good
relationship with
hitler before he in fact invaded europe
the rusty okay
okay i want to read that one back to you
we had a good relationship with hitler
until he invaded europe now you might be
thinking but that was a long time ago
joe what are you talking about
i actually did the math so i think he's
talking about if let's say he's talking
about roughly 1935
early hitler uh joe got into the senate
in 1921 right that was a hundred
years ago roughly and so that means 14
the difference between 1921 1935 so for
14 years joe biden was in the senate
because he was in
in 1921 you see what i did there and uh
apparently he had a good relationship
with hitler
at the time um look it's another stupid
line it's a it's a
callus an inauthentic way of comparing
trump to hitler
and and it's it's actually just kind of
gross it is just kind of gross
anyway in the in the final minute here
um i would say this
the fireworks ain't over the fireworks
seem to be subdued tonight
uh but we have these 10 days left lord
only knows what's going to come up
um but you really have to just think
think
think for yourself you don't have to hey
i wrote a book it was you know thinking
for yourself in an age of unreason right
think for yourself and which which
future do you think is right
and i i think you know where i fall on
this thing it's like if you want any
sort of america that seems kind of
consistent
to anything we've known i think
bizarrely
donald trump is the one that can save
that thing he's saving conservatives
conservatism obviously as i said this
morning
because he's doing conservative things
right so if you're a conservative
you may not like the way he talks but he
is doing conservative things and your
guys never won you tried it with mccain
you tried it with romney
and oddly for the liberals he's the one
saving liberalism do you think
joe biden is going to stop critical race
theory rampaging through the
institutions
do you think joe biden is going to stand
up to racial quotas that will be coming
to the federal institutions that will be
coming to your job and everywhere else
no donald trump did so all of the things
that make liberalism so wonderful in its
truest sense
trump is the one actually saving them do
you think biden can save these things if
you think
biden is the one if you think biden is
the chosen one and he can
not only do all of the things that he
never did in the past
but also stopped the oncoming
white walkers who are coming i think
those they were the white walkers i
always fell asleep in the middle of that
show but the things that were coming
they were on their way and they were bad
and there was a wall
if you think biden is the guy that can
do that well then you should vote for
biden but if
if you don't think he has the strength
and fortitude to stand up to it
and you don't really understand why he
didn't do any of things he's promising
in those 47 years
or why he didn't even do them in his
eight years or any of that
well then you got a choice to make and
and that's where everybody will be left
so for anyone of you that's watching
this that's on the fence
it's like you got to figure it out for
yourself man
as joe would say come on man figure it
out for yourself so think for yourself
and uh maybe we'll do a bonus show
tomorrow uh-oh
uh-oh uh oh my producer michael just
looked at me like his head was going to
explode maybe we'll do a q a
tomorrow let's let's see just to follow
up on all this stuff uh join us at
rubinreport.com by the way i i did a
live chat
during the debate where i can actually
talk directly to you guys because
obviously the youtube comments section
uh although it's been pretty clean
lately i do quickly glance through it
every now and again and you guys have
been on
point um and we've been it's been a
little less trolley it's obviously
totally overwhelming to get in there so
i can communicate with you guys directly
and respond to you directly at
reubenreport.com
we've got live chat and they had free
video and all that good stuff all right
i'm going to be joining glenn back in
just a couple minutes over on the blaze
tv
thanks for watching everybody and i hope
you're not too wasted
and i'll see you tomorrow